os dois andaram muito bem vindos
a idéia é com votos poderão ver pelo
haiti vamos lutar com a união muito
grande
eu adoro adoro aquela emoção está no ar
há no ar apesar de não viajar muito né
porque usamos muito o avião hoje em dia
um avião usado para tudo mesmo um uso
muito bom a universidade atlântica
desafio para pilotar aqui o avião eo
efeito é o movimento de aviões eu acho
que dá um vídeo engraçado e com o mesmo
mais um povo muito fácil de pilotar o
avião mas vamos falar um pouco sobre
atlântica porque foram muito simpáticos
comigo é prematuro também com 30 bilhões
e engenharias clientes e essas coisas
meu atlético tem um curso ficar com isso
que a engenharia aeronáutica
meu deus como em outras regiões têm um
laboratório em que se entende por que
fui lá brujita atlântica fica na nova
fábrica da pólvora em oeiras brasil e
imagens mas não foi de mil é muito lindo
gigante também favoritos são
laboratórios mil b que tem muita coisa
tem muito que me quinta meu mundo não só
que o ataque mas eu encontrei um na mão
um braço do menino um laboratório como
um louco tudo isso para dizer que vocês
ganharem escuras vocês vão poder brilhar
na erba em madri e encargos também
espanha na sequência de carbono
logo vocês vão ter algum sucesso obter
trabalho com trabalho vamos manter muito
dinheiro e eu te pergunto em outra coisa
é melhor todos os estágios curriculares
nas fábricas e nos laboratórios
percorrem a licenciatura desde o
primeiro ano letivo é muito bom é único
em portugal
aproveitem o primeiro não tem feito
discursos porque eu tenho nem pensei
nisso
ao todo mas só vamos lá então abrir o
nosso avião o dia 14 que nos foram seu e
não sabe como é que funciona ou jogamos
bem não estariam eu acho que havia um
branco azulão pouco né é sem graça né
então que resolvi fazer você um dia
inteiro a pintar o avião explodiu um
design pregão eu fico brutal mesmo pois
o envio de imagens
[Música]
eles passaram de que a pilotagem do
avião já estava ter uma meta você já
sabe o lance por uma meta clube para
tentar bater o espanhol em lights neste
vídeo e voltar a trazer mais brinquedos
deste ano tempo aviões drone os carros
eu apoie mesmo vídeo quero muito muito
voltar a fazer isso mais fácil apoiar e
nuno mas só seguir a conversa e vamos lá
para fora pilotar o avião embora não só
de que fora não vamos lá então testar o
nosso avião pois o blog porém lindo meu
e agora vamos tentar que um tal eu só
tem drogas até agora não está perdido
mas no manual em português não atuamos
bem no inglês
ok então as instruções têm tudo a ver
com o comando das filhas da mãe
a câmara não tem câmera integrada anel
mas enquanto estava a pintar o avião ea
câmera passeio acabou por perder no ano
e distintas e eu não sou nem maior foi
fora do paulinho e manoel uma câmera
para o lixo agora não tira o comando até
agora supostamente para configurar a
tecla para baixo e escutamos logo podem
ver com o avião é muito leve tenha sido
vendido há por que não chamar não é
muito mais mesmo funciona agora está
agora tá com a suposta intenção de criar
uma trilha ou de baixo e bateria
mesmo porque não trazer nada de entrar
aqui bateria vão circular aqui
esgotamento agora vai ficar cinco
segundos parado sozinho a sério as
moedinhas grid e esta faça fazenda da
bahia de partida embora tá pronto do 3 2
1 11
[Aplausos]
cuidado com muito vento então é bom
começar desde lá pra cá e eu vou
contratar pessoal primeiro teste de vôo
321 bairro a porta da nossa casa é muito
grande com 32 pontos
otava uma roda só com nós somos do curso
atlântica
olha só resta rezar dois malucos meu
maior bancada da câmara da capital o
portão mas estamos buscando trabalhar
por mim vou estar em algum campo
a campanha estava em casa e ouvi um
mundial estava ali me surpreendeu o fato
de que nesta com mais longas
vamos tentar montar aqui vou para lá mas
não deixa mais atuante que eu sei de
onde supostamente estava junto com este
está pronta com esta funciona para lá
vou tentar mandar lá que eu vou lá agora
[Música]
o meu bairro do anil
ae
[Risadas]
só vamos agora fazer uma corrida nossa
região com o casa coloca capita que não
fez o avião é mais rápido ou não na
galiza na verdade eu acho que não acho
que vou perder o meu baptismo
agora é bem mais perigoso
eu não vou ter que arranjar mesmo agora
no rock só mas vamos falar a língua
quarto saber que posso fazer e está
avaliado não foi assim ficou o leão tudo
de bom mas que ainda funciona mas que
vem que eu construo o bial então alterar
aspectos de junto com outra coisa
qualquer tipo um bar com carros que vêm
ver já estava em deixar o nosso lá e
talvez não fosse um videogame este avião
portanto é isso fiquei mãe e até a
próxima